[Applause]
[Music]
Yeah. Cuz I look just like you.
Where we used to
say every
day Heat. Heat. Heat.
[Music]
I
know. I know. I don't
[Applause]
[Music]
care.
After all, I just don't like you. Heat.
Heat.
[Music]
Heat. Heat. Heat. Heat.
Yeah. I
know. I
[Music]
know. I know. I don't
care. Baby, believe
me. And you had a chance to destroy
everything that
[Music]
you Heat. Heat.
Heat
up
here. Heat up
[Music]
here.
Heat up here.
[Music]
Oh my god, friends. You would not
believe how difficult it was to get that
video. It's always so busy down at the
Tidal Basin here in DC for the cherry
blossoms, but this year was especially
so because peak bloom was just over the
course of one weekend. So, I am glad
that I caught the video and I hope that
you all enjoyed it. Uh, real quickly,
uh, if you'd like to get a set of those,
uh, Orb Poy Pros that I was using in
this video, you can do so and get 10%
off by using the promo code drexfactor
with a zero instead of an O over at
ultraoy.com. Once again, that is
drexfactor with a zero instead of an O.
And thank you so much to Ultraoy for
sponsoring this video. Y'all are
awesome. And speaking of people that are
awesome, uh, I owe thanks to the friends
of the channel. Big thanks to Dark Monk,
Fire Mecca, Flowfests, Flow Toys, Pyro
Terraite Toys, and Ultraoy for helping
to make the videos on this channel
possible. You can learn more about all
these amazing companies and the work
they're doing to support flow artists
like yourself by checking out the links
that I have down in the description of
this video. And special thanks to the
non-B business friend of the channel,
Becca Beckonin. Thank you so very much
for supporting my channel, my work, and
my mission. And of course, this video
and all the videos on this channel
wouldn't even be possible in the first
place were it not for my amazing
supporters on Patreon. In particular,
I'd love to give a shout out to my flow
patrons who are listed on screen right
now. Thank you all so much. You are
awesome. And if you'd like to get your
name in the credits or access to a host
of other possible rewards, you can go
sign up for my Patreon over at
patreon.com/drexfactorpo. I'll include a
link to it down in the description as
well as up in the cards. In addition to
getting access to some awesome rewards,
you'll also be helping me out in my
mission to bring PO spinning and flow
arts to the whole wide world. So, go
check that out, please. And thank you.
And if you'd like to check out more of
my flow sessions, I will leave you links
to a playlist of that of those videos.
Uh, link down in the description as well
as up on screen. Thank you so much for
watching. Make sure to get out and flow
yourselves today and I'll see you with a
new video real soon. Take care now.
Peace.